Phil going in with a contingency plan is
mustard heart now no because he went in
there and he went in there through the
meat on this because
I'm saying all I'm saying is
it the baddest who he himself has said
I've been over there for years trying to
reforms this all of a sudden he went
over there with meat on the table again
that's that's how it went down uh it
didn't go down that way you know you
know what's funny and you know how to go
down that muster Hearts like to revise
whatever they want to do
I just I just listen to y'all guys talk
and y'all Battle of the mustard heart
continue to continue to muscle that's
all I'll say all I'm saying it may
behoove you someday to take ow with a
bit of humility
I'm not doing that I'm gonna take my w
how I like it I like I like my w with a
little sauce on it
you don't like my W's hey
what the hell is a slathery muscles
only thing you do remember is these wins
oh my God so let King go so that he
could oh basically reiterate what I say
and try to say basically obliterate try
and base it and try to say it in a
different way that makes it sound like
Phil walked in there with his chest out
because he didn't do that I'm gonna show
you where you're wrong I'm gonna tell
you right now and you know what's over
there
the man went over there where humility
as he should have
and he got the job done and I appreciate
that he ain't going there swinging
nobody he was he wasn't throwing hands
listen I know I know what I saw oh here
we go you know where we go
this is King making inferences from
pictures
my man came out looking like Goldberg
you came out you can't front when they
had your smoke and electricity and the
lights
and Phil went to Japan and threw cargo
do not associate me with Phil and his
beat please
we got to get to it oh you know what
we're here for kids you you know
obviously the the discussion last week
was very prophetic because um we we did
talk about Square Enix and you had some
very strong proclamations you you had to
bend the knee I will say I went from
zero percent chance of that happening to
like a 15 now you got it we got to give
King his flowers we we all looked at him
again like we always do when he makes
both Proclamation sometimes like yo
that's wild he really saying this like
acquisition or Square eatings without
any information and then boom and that
shows up on stage like King I gotta like
what is going through your mind right
now when you say Phil Spencer on stage
with Square Enix heads talking about
this relationship and let's be clear
this relationship has been Rocky and
inconsistent at best for the last couple
of years so what do you make of this and
do you still stand on your theory that
there's going to come let's go check it
out the only thing that's been Rocky and
inconsistent was the old CEO
money was on the table this is before
the AKA
um ABK deal money was on the table yo
listen we want to do this we want to do
that we want to purchase this and it was
a deal in place
Microsoft came back to the table
so yo like nah we need more bread on
that like you know you saw somebody
wallet before they left and they came
back you raised the price oh man so
that's where the the talks was breaking
down then ABK uh became available and it
was like let's let's go handle that real
quick we can double back on these dudes
because there was a point in time where
tons of Square Enix games was showing up
on Game Pass that is true and nobody
thought that you would get uh any of the
Kingdom Hearts seriously on Game Pass
like all of them showed up and then all
these obscure Final Fantasy games
started showing up and we was like yo
what's going on with this relationship
where they going with it well come to
find out when the APK information came
out the stuff that Sony did not want you
to see
um somebody had a whole dossier
that it's true they pulled out this is
the square folder
and in that folder they had everything
all the ins and outs and they were
approved for purchase like they were
this is the higher up said yeah we see
what y'all doing we like that we
purchased them
okay so that information is there so
we're trying to figure it out like oh
snap all right so the double back
happened so what happened what do you
think happened wrong so as soon as this
time these dudes is over there they feel
like all right back on the grind grind
never stops when you're a hustler yeah I
never stopped so he was like all right
back to what I was talking about back to
my regularly scheduled program went
right over back to Japan new CEO in
place new CEO in place uh forget the
gentleman's uh carry you and um yeah
that former he took over from uh what's
his name yasoki Masada so he stepped
down as president and then Takashi Kiryu
is now the new product and I believe the
timing was very interesting in
conjunction to this announcement because
I believe it's um he the new CEO started
in June and Final Fantasy 14 Xbox
announced in July
I I used to watch called bunk and there
was an episode where the mayor what
what's the thing would you do when you
get someone out of jail you um pardon
them yeah so there's a criminal that the
mayor wouldn't pardon so that Karma's
like we gotta get that mayor our body
because we got
Instagram
fly this new uh position
s
it's like we can't buy the company so
we're gonna buy the leaders they put a
new guy in a little bit more agreeable
no I don't I don't even think what
you're saying is is factual what you
think I'm just joking no no no no I
don't think they literally went in there
and said we're gonna no that's gonna
give you a paycheck to get it done
that's the hard version of it but let me
give you the real version of it
we want to be sold the boy like we want
to be sold we don't pretty up ourselves
we don't we don't separate it from Iowa
we don't did all this other stuff
Dynamics with everybody's gone and we
don't have the person in place the guy
to keep vetoing what we want to do so
you know what we're gonna give you all
if you can't refuse you got to get up
out of here and um you take this
severance package the moment that he
takes a severance package and disappear
the most uh accoladed MMO is showing up
Final Fantasy 14. they had a private
investigator to walk in it like are
these you in these pictures
they had the dossier and he slid it out
and said
in this shot was this was this you
hitting her
blackmail blackmail
he said he said
um wait Phil went over there with with
the footage with the tape put it on the
table except
it wasn't even filmed the investigator
leaves then Phil walks in the Phil sits
down so what's up yeah they did your
silky like that my suit inside like yeah
so so shut up and the new CEO I'm
greeting Phil if y'all look at the the
um the picture when they all hold their
hands with the Kumbaya yes yes
they had to show you on the stage
this is real this is happening for days
I said something about lifting something
at an envelope and king oh so happened
listen I'm I'm about that life I'm about
this podcast in life but
the thing about it is Phil is ready
he's not he's not about going to Japan
and playing around and having drinks and
not making moves he's there to make
moves he came out of the wrestler's
tunnel people to arouse and Applause so
we're gonna have all right to help with
all the monster heart talk everything's
showing up B everything everything is
showing up everything Final Fantasy
remake
you're saying a bag wasn't involved in
it no listen money's always involved in
everything that's what I said he agrees
not like how you talking though
everything's coming
watch this right
watch when that ABK deal is complete
who's next everybody keep yelling out
Sega no Sega next in line
there was
there was a dossier bro like if you go
into the into the FBI uh Department
these faces no they have a folder with
your face on it yo imagine imagine that
it's next time like you go into that
thing and ABK goes in there he's like yo
why is there an X over our logo oh cause
we got you
no yo look like the dossier if if you
want to tell everybody about Adrian's
office and your face is on a folder
start getting your Affairs in order
they got information
do you find this weird this is this is
not weird this is not coincidence the
next people they pick up is square the
next they gonna go buy them outright
whatever's gonna happen is going to
happen so if you have those little
contracts in the background and final
fantastic can never make it when we buy
you and guess what's gonna happen
what I love about Phil
Dominus Maximus really expensive first
of his name who did that for you kid huh
who did that for y'all who Who had who
when y'all when y'all boot up that Final
Fantasy
I play Final Fantasy on my PlayStation I
mean the service was trash but this guy
said
I want this because like addict said
this is gonna give me the most
visibility
I don't want a one and done
I want something that's gonna last in
perpetuity that Final Fantasy is
associated with this console so once I
get the millions of MMO players over
here then check that out and have that
Curiosity then we're gonna release the
hounds on them
when they purchase Square
I just want y'all all to come back here
and just give me my flowers I told you a
week before it happened what was gonna
happen then you're so like on a Thursday
like Phil is outside and he's holding
hands on the stage and all PlayStation
dudes uh we don't really like 14 anyway
shut up I'm so tired I'm so tired of you
you you hold everything cherished to
your heart and what Phil is doing is
he's little by little removing all the
cards out of your hands best hand of
Yu-Gi-Oh I've ever seen in my life my
guy he put that death card down you know
that card that you can't move left and
you can't move right and that Dragon
come out and nothing that you do is ever
gonna stop it that's when you're
becoming at and my app predictions for
you guys is happening every day and it's
exhilarated because I'm for this King
they're coming for this I just had to
put on a Crown because y'all forget who
I am sometimes y'all forget who the hell
I am and y'all out here oh King is
talking out his butt yeah but my butt
and Phil went over there and said
I want you
and I'm gonna have you
you can do that anyway yeah
we think that like Microsoft's good like
well obviously not King but you know
obviously Acquisitions is
something in their future and we think
yeah babe
maybe we ain't putting two or three
maybe this oh I had it coming around
maybe they just going for Sega they
ain't just going I mean maybe they go
for the whole street but we be this is
the thing right when especially with the
GamePad it's the game pass is the key
right because if without Game Pass you
could say okay we're gonna buy these
these Studios or whatever and we're
gonna sell games the way we know always
have and we're gonna keep doing the way
what we're doing Game Pass change the
whole equation because Game Pass now you
they need to own everything what does it
what does it behoove them to pay a
million millions of dollars for rentals
of games why right so
the game passes to play they're going to
keep buying it's never going to stop
it's never going to stop so solve I mean
be careful because you know people get
so sensitive when you talk consolidation
in the industry
like that people are going to say we're
fun to do today
you're voting for the death of the
industry no it's just this is the thing
all right I'm voting for the deficit you
know what you know what bothers me about
that you act like that like this whole
other aspect of the game industry can't
continue to thrive and and grow the way
it's doing I see that PlayStation is
take taking the baby steps right they've
done this stuff with the PS Plus or
whatever the fact of the matter is
they're still very successful at selling
games the way they sell them yep and
remove from that right
it doesn't to me it doesn't behoove them
to try to continue to to Wade and Waters
that Xbox has gone in keep doing what
you're doing keep giving people those
250 million dollar day one you know
bangers or whatever and and keep doing
that to me this the idea that game pass
becomes so big that it gets they swallow
up PlayStation as well I mean that that
actually could happen but what I mean
what I mean is that the two different
ways of thinking continue they can
survive because you see Nintendo and I I
refuse to keep seeing Nintendo is this
other thing you see Nintendo continuing
to do things their way and be successful
and I don't see the direct comparison
being an issue go ahead the funny thing
solve like I might go on here and cap a
lot for them to buy Sega Sega is a dream
score Enix to me is a fantasy yeah
literally
literally it is literally the thing is I
would lose my I lose my my stuff if they
bought Sega if they bought Square eggs I
might I might have just passed away from
from a heart attack I don't know about
my mind could not concept that it's
crazy it is crazy because first of all
the cultural stuff right yeah the idea
of going in and purchasing a Japanese
company that way not like a third-party
way right not not the way they did it
with uh with with Bethesda right and and
um in the studio over there they if you
buying a Japanese company directly as an
American company stop smiling stuff
they're gonna say you don't know what
you're wishing for yeah
they said you it's a sad future be
careful though don't cheer yeah that's
you know what I'm tired of that that
talk it is ridiculous change happens all
the time and change can suck change is
not something that any of us want
especially swapping change the way we're
seeing in the game industry but the fact
of the matter is you you know how they
say you know it was the Jurassic Park
saying life finds a way it finds a way
it's just everybody's going to adapt how
they need to adapt but I firmly believe
that PlayStation can keep doing what
they're doing as long as the quality is
there they don't have missteps with dumb
things like again I I as a PS VR2 owner
it's a great piece of tech that is
collecting dust in my house and there
are some games that are cool but they
don't even promote it like they don't
even promote it so stuff like that just
keep focusing on the great games figure
out more ways to make them faster right
and and expand that way obviously you
have your service games coming that
hopefully one or two hit and it's gonna
bolster your bottom line there
this idea that game the game pass is
going to become so big that nobody's
going to see beyond that and no other
way of selling games is going to be
viable is is stupid to me it is just
fear-mongering I don't understand it I
really don't understand it listen
there's a lot of stuff going on this was
this was super surprising I'll jump in
yeah I didn't I didn't see this coming I
know you know Phil and the team I've
always said they want to improve that
relation but it really got bad I think I
think you know what especially the
Remake Final Fantasy 7 remake you know
at one point we did see verbiage that
okay after one year it'll come right and
then you know obviously octopath comes
out you know you see part one and then
part two comes out like where's this
where's the pixel remaster I lost my
marbles over octopus travel too oh I
know you did you know listen shout out
to Flame um in in the chat you know he's
he's a big octopath guy as well as far
as well as Maddie and you just start to
see the inconsistency and I do think
there's a lot of Truth to what king is
saying and ref to some way that
relationship went really bad with the
previous CEO now I think King has a good
theory you know look we gotta Bend and
need a cake let's just call it like we
ain't even playing with you bro like you
you beyond Northwest
ever since the whole the line movement
uh you you you will be on fire but the
thing what I gotta give you is like
to see this is very symbolic right it's
very symbolic and we we didn't see this
one coming right so look they're looking
to improve the relationship you know for
this what I think I think that at the
end of the day
we have to give Phil his flowers and
this is why a lot of people I know they
oh he lies oh you know I don't
understand why Xbox fans Revere him
right these are the reasons why because
again it's looking at the console
objectively and all their weaknesses and
all their faults right and since his
Inception into the brand it's been a
systematic fixing of things that Xbox
fans have wanted right so it's just like
man systems underpowered all right boom
Here Comes Xbox One X hey Here Comes
this amazing service that is Game Pass
it starts to become a trend and it's
like the talk was they ain't never gonna
do nothing in Japan we never going like
it was always these roadblocks and then
again regardless to you can poo-poo it
and say oh bro it's just one game though
right but there's symbolism to what king
is saying in reference to going over
there getting here's the thing that I
thought was interesting no one's really
talk about the Square Enix account
tweeted this and put the Emojis about
you know Xbox and you know we're excited
you know to see what's going on like
this is a full
unified front marketing right yep not
just one side say hey guys we we did it
we got the the the team that has been
resisted is saying hey guys we did this
too so again I don't know what it means
for the future you know what it means I
know you got you know by looking when
are we gonna stop questioning because
it's just baffling to us right like this
is happening because this is changing
right oh what it is is let's let's keep
it above
they were putting theyself up we thought
they were putting themselves off of Sony
right
then we started seeing all these games
and landing on Xbox right
and then the APK thing went and then
something weird happened yes right I
agree with your theory yeah that sounded
like some jilted situation say like we
know they were on the marriage list
right to be put a ring on their finger
and they got like theoretically let's
say they got theoretically left at the
order
ABK happens you're stopping everything
you do I got to go get Beyonce because
yeah like ABK wasn't on the list right
right so we know that is something that
literally happened fell from this guy
like oh they they down and we could get
that they were they were probably just
as shocked that they were able to buy
ABK as we were when we found that they
were buying anything exactly so that
happens let's say Square relationship
was talking through this this list right
right as well as other companies Bungie
was on that list you saw everybody that
was on the list either in a holding
pattern or got a quiet by someone else
because embracer then grabbed up the
square metal Square started exactly
Crystal Dean all that stuff started
happening so the reason why people like
you is y'all y'all camping for a 14 year
old game you got to look at the Tea
Leaves they also said future games it
didn't just say oh this is just one game
and that's what's coming out in the
future right so the Final Fantasy and
remember when I said right and I can
still play that Final Fantasy remake yet
but something is holding me back and I
said I'm not playing until it come out
on that Xbox you have said that that you
was gonna do it and I want to see it
done I I just know how Petty my dude is
and I know that when I fight when I
Street Fighter 5 was only over there and
he said I wanted to play Street Fighter
on my mind yeah he said and it'll never
happen again we was like you don't got
no control well Street Fighter 6 is on
Xbox right now right now yeah I remember
the days when Tekken wouldn't make the
platform he was like that's again this
is why he is revered by Xbox fan every
issue for the most still a lot of stuff
but you can't take away the course
correction during his regime you can't
take that away from him and you can't
take away game pass so again there's
always going to be ups and downs but if
you look at the resume objectively it is
very impressive what he's doing to try
to turn the brand around you cannot take
that away from him okay I would say
right now
you can make a strong argument he's the
you can make a noun you can make it now
absolutely I think
if he continues it's the only thing that
Phil has lacked in my opinion is a
consistent quality the quality games
if he leaves after he's achieved that
right you can make an argument he's the
best executive ever being gaming yeah if
he's able to achieve that that you know
if if Starfield comes out and it's a hit
Fable comes out because I consider even
though let's say he retires in two years
even at two years
I would still give him stuff like Fable
because the majority that's like it's
like we said like the the Don matric
error the Phil Spencer error like even
after he leaves those first couple games
is still going to be under what his
leadership was and if he can
self-correct you know and people get
like this twisted like he has had good
games in his era yeah yeah like butts
for every great game like a gears five
yeah it's been something that was
underwhelming like around absolutely
absolutely and I think that is the
biggest thing that's holding him from
being like one of the best yeah for me
Executives ever for me I'm just I know
kids will be mad when I put the
traveling on a Sunday so to speak for me
as far as regimes as far as Xbox
leadership right it's always going to be
Peter Moore here like Phil you can make
the augment his already I'm just gonna
wait until the star feels the the
hellblades the Fable just long as
they're good if they come out and
they're good then that's his class of
2018. yeah that's his draft picks that's
them bearing fruit if that his draft
picks bear fruit and execute
between him and Peter Moore is
Peter Moore established pillars yes yes
all right and um
that's that's the only thing that he has
to do you know he he established
platforms he made Xbox uh a brand that
you can stand behind right
Game Pass he's done these things but at
the end of the day like yeah they can
like use a sob web Dave
it's about them games and if those games
don't hit then he won't hit so he got he
got to land those games gonna land and I
think Sofia starts to turn I think
starfield's Game of the Year this year
anyway so I think it's gonna it's gonna
be big I'll just finish up real quick
and just say look this was I'm with King
there is a lot of symbolism here I don't
know if this is going to mean an
acquisition but there's a lot of
symbolism here and and he knows that by
going on stage with Yoshi p and getting
that deal done as well as looks like you
know future partnership is going to
improve it feels like it's going to
improve based on the comments we're
seeing from both sides that's it's a big
deal and um again I just Hawken back to
I want to give them their flowers as far
as what they've done in Japan you know
shout out to the Queen Sarah Bond you
know took pictures with her took
pictures with her just said you know you
know yeah whatever but um it's hard to
celebrate people in the game and
actually do things and you know that I
meet but um anyway
um John Jokes Aside but I do think that
they have been on a mission since the
Tokyo game shows the last two three
years to continue to make the groundwork
to put in the work to to improve that
and you like to see it and that as a
person who enjoys playing on the
platform these are the these are those
missing things these deficits that
they're trying to I just want to get
Dave's real quick thought on hierarchy
as far as but then we move on um as far
as Phil's you know um leadership and as
far as his tenure excuse me his tenure
at Xbox like what do you see because I
know there's a lot of criticism
sometimes and rightfully so we saw the
redfall stuff we saw some things that
durian like yo what's going on 2022 how
do you know first party games whatever
whatever but like now that you're
looking at this where we sit now and
then for the future where you have him
in Xbox hierarchy so to speak